[Applaudissements]
la liste la gauche unie pour que tu
rappes respire menée par ali rabais
vient de remporter l'élection municipale
partielle
il a obtenu 58 % des suffrages des
trappistes la confiance exprimée par les
trappistes est remarquable une victoire
dès le premier tour face à un front
incohérent certes mais qui a été assez
virulent une campagne qui a été violente
dont j'ai été la cible hommes de
calomnie diffamation d'injure répété à
l'origine de ce scrutin partiel
l'annulation des résultats de l'élection
municipale du 28 juin 2020 avec la
victoire d'ali rabais son adversaire
othman nzru avait fait un recours devant
le tribunal administratif
pour ce nouveau scrutin il s'est
présenté autour d'un large rassemblement
républicain avec mustapha larbaoui et
l'ancien maire socialiste guy malandain
le candidat de l'union républicaine pur
trap a recueilli 34% des voix il a réagi
par voie de communiqué ce soir les
trappistes ont choisi de rallier
ralliera b nous n'avons visiblement pas
réussi à convaincre aucune alternative
républicaine était possible ni a bien
expliqué le double jeu d'al hira b où le
danger des méthodes qu'ils utilisent
nous en prenons acte la liste trappe à
gauche de l'udc miserait a rassemblé 5 %
des suffrages une déception pour le
candidat déjà penché sur son rôle dans
l'opposition on a beaucoup insisté par
exemple sur le thème de l'éducation sur
le fait qu'il fallait plus de qualité
plus de diversité des propositions pour
les enfants on continuera à défendre ce
la dernière liste de ce scrutin lutte
ouvrière faire entendre le camp des
travailleurs avec patrick planque en
tête de liste pour lui le combat est
déjà ailleurs quand on est travailleur
quand on est ouvrier on n'a jamais rien
obtenu par les élections c'est toujours
par nos luttes collectives et
et c'est ça qu'on va défendre dans ces
élections c'est ça qu'on a défendu et
qu'on continuera à défendre pour cette
élection partielle le taux de
participation atteint les 41 % un
chiffre supérieur au premier tour de
2020 avec 34 % des votants